let's jump into the story from the
guardian Ukraine applies for NATO
membership after Russia annexes
territory Vladimir zielinski dismisses
moscow's ceremony as a farce and rules
out negotiations with Putin so there you
go there uh there he is he signed the
paperwork I thought it was funny because
like I don't know what that paperwork
says before I know it could be like an
order form for Giordano's or something
you know but he signed it and we watched
him do it and he said it was to join
NATO if Ukraine were admitted into NATO
right now we would formally be in World
War III correct because of Article Five
yes what is the Article Five is that
you've got to defend the new LS yeah
common defense but if they're already at
War then they wouldn't trigger Article
Five as far as I don't I don't know
actually but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure that effectively that's saying
World War and that Russia is now War of
the NATO alliance yeah it's a mutual
Alliance pack so if one member of NATO
gets gets attacked all of NATO has to
come in and protect that one particular
country that got attacked